Well, good morning church.
Uh, my name's John, one of the pastors here.
It's great to see you.
Uh, this morning we're continuing a series we've begun a
couple weeks ago through the chapter of Romans 12,
and it's called Realigned.
And it's looking at what a transformed life in Christ
actually looks like day to day.
What does that even mean for us?
Every moment as we get into it today, I'd love
to tell you about one of the mentors in my life.
A man, most of you have no idea who it even is,
but has made a massive impact on me.
A man named Ryan Reese.
Now Ryan, uh, moved to Fairview as I graduated high school
when he became the youth pastor
of a church there in Fairview.
And, uh, it was the church that a bunch
of my younger friends were going to.
And so every time I would go home, I would hang out
with them, which meant I hang out with him as well.
And so we just clicked really quickly.
Uh, theology was new to me at the time,
and so he was really deep in theology.
So I was just growing and asking questions and,
and it just developed over time, a really deep relationship.
Well, years later after I'd then become a youth pastor in
Stillwater, uh, that church,
they invited me back to preach there.
Now, it was one of my first sermons I'd ever preached.
And let's just say it was a struggle.
Uh, it was not one of my better sermons.
I, I know I was just stumbling through it.
Yet we go to lunch at my grandparents' house and invite Ryan
and his wife over and at lunch we're sitting there
and across the table from me, he looks across
and he has a rye smile and a, a slight chuckle.
And he says, you're gonna be a pastor someday.
It just affirmed me. It honored me.
See, here's what I didn't know at the time.
I, I didn't know that that's what God wanted for my life.
I was just doing ministry 'cause I kind
of defaulted into it, fell into it there in Stillwater
and I was just sort of playing around and having a good time
and had a, had a good purpose in the moment.
But I didn't know what the future held.
But he looked at me and affirmed and valued and,
and looked at at my future and called me to something more.
And maybe, maybe for you, it was a coach
who spent some extra time helping develop you.
Whenever things went home were hard.
Or maybe it was a parent or a grandparent
who just spoke life into you your whole life
and you saw what God had.
Or maybe it was a teacher
or a friend who was looking at your life
and said, here's, here's where I could see you going.
Or Here's, here's what you're great at. Here's who you are.
And affirming you and honoring you.
The point is, Ryan saw great value in my life,
even when I may not have seen it, he saw it.
I start there because today we're gonna talk about how
that kind of stuff should be normal within the church
where every corner is filled with people affirming
and encouraging and valuing
and celebrating the gifts of each other, all pointing to
God's purpose in real ways, in people's lives.
If we were to take stock right now,
how would we say we're doing at that church?
How, how would we say we are doing at that?
Are we really living out Ephesians 4 29 which says
that no corrupting talk should come outta their mouth,
but is only what is full of grace.
Only what's going to build others up
really towards God's purpose, speaking life into people
for God's purpose, for them in their lives.
God's will. How are we doing at that?
Most of us, again, not just here
but broad church experience in all of our lives, most of us
have experienced the exact opposite of that, sadly,
slander, backbiting, gossip, competing to try
to win more and be honored more than everybody else
and put people down so you can be lifted up.
That's what we've mostly experienced
and that's why what we're gonna study today is so critical
because the command we're gonna see in Romans 12 verse 10 is
to outdo one another in showing honor.
Like if we're gonna compete at anything, compete at this
showing honor,
outdoing each other in it, let's compete at that.
Now, lemme just set a a bit of vision.
We go into this today, just a little vision in our hearts
of, of something that, that, just imagine the culture
that we would have a church would have if this
command was fully true of each one of us.
Like what kind of atmosphere would that be? Right?
Just think about that. How sweet that would be
for everyone walking around competing at out,
doing one another and showing honor
that's incredible to be a part of.
And so what we're gonna see today is a pathway to get there.
God's word's gonna leave us a pathway,
just a glimpse of it.
What it first means is that we must be humble
before we would ever get there.
We've gotta be humble in order to honor,
but then honor itself actually flows from God
through us to others.
That's how we get there.
So let's start by praying
and asking God to show us what he wants
to show us in His word.
Lord, we pray in desperation
that we need you every hour.
We need you. You are our defense,
our righteousness, oh God, how we need you.
And so we need you in this moment in your word
that this is your word, not mine.
This is not, not 10 steps to a better life.
This is your word.
And we trust your spirit to move through your word,
to change our hearts that we need you.
God, we, we can't do this naturally.
We just wanna compete and win and put others down.
But Lord, change our hearts that we would be more honoring
to one another because of who you are and what you've done.
So help us God and change us God in Jesus' name. Amen.
So again, this the phrase we're studying today, again,
we're just taking pieces of Romans 12
through the next few months.
The second half of verse 10 in Romans 12, it says,
outdo one another in showing honor.
Now there's some interesting words used here
and I wanna focus first on that word honor.
Not just because it's the subject to the message, but
because it's a really deep,
profound word in the original language.
It's used a many times,
probably a couple dozen times in the Bible.
And it's used in a couple different ways.
Like there's some nuanced meanings to it.
First it's used as we might think it is honor in the sense
of respecting someone that you honor them, which again,
we kind of understand that inherently.
But there's others as well.
It's used in relation to nobility or,
or specialness like a king.
Or you know when you go to a a courtroom,
well not when you go, but when you
watch somebody in a courtroom, right?
They talk to the judge, they say, your honor, right?
So that's a sense of there's a specialness to that person.
A king, your honor. That's what that word is used as. Well.
Now there's a third
and it's used in the sense of dealing with money,
like the cost of something
or that you value this thing this much, that you're willing
to pay this much for it.
That's also honor.
And so there's all of that wrapped into this word.
But notice in Romans 1210, the orientation
of the way it's used, here it is toward others.
Now, when we talk about value and specialness
and all these things and, and your unique
and all that stuff, most of us, let's just be clear, right?
Most of us typically have no problem seeing ourselves
as pretty special, as valuable.
Like where, where do you think like
participation trophies came from, right?
Like kids these days. My generation, by the way,
we lament participation trophies.
Our parents, you're the ones who gave those to us.
So it's not our fault we, but,
but the kids get told you're special all the time.
You're unique, you have something to give, right?
They, we have no problem seeing ourselves that way.
But do you see others as unique and valuable and special?
Do you see others in an honoring kind of way?
That's the rub. That's where it's gonna be a little harder
because innate in us is not, it's not natural
to honor others.
We're we're competing that we wanna win. It's about us.
So that's the point here. If we're going
to actually apply this command, James says,
don't just be hearers of the word, be doers of it.
We're gonna actually command this,
this command, we're gonna obey it.
Outdo one another, showing honor. How do we get there?
First, it starts with our humility.
If we're going to do this
and we should want to, it starts with our humility.
'cause just think about it, right? If I'm gonna honor you
as a person, if I'm gonna treat you as valuable,
if I'm gonna respect you, if I'm gonna treat you as special,
if I'm gonna value you, I've got to be humble first, right?
Unless I'm lying, I have to be humble to actually do this,
to see you as valuable.
I can't think too highly of myself.
I can't make my life all about me.
If I'm going to honor you, I can't make it about me.
Can't just be about self has to be about you,
which is a humble posture.
I love how Philippians two frames this,
especially Philippians two, verses three and four.
This is the apostle Paul talking to the church in Philippi
and he's saying, here's how you
maintain unity within your church.
The momentum is to fracture you.
Here's how you maintain unity.
This is what he said, verses three and four.
He says, do nothing from selfish ambition or conceit,
but in humility, count others more
significant than yourselves.
Let each of you look not only to his own interests
but also to the interests of others.
Like doesn't that sound like honoring
each other from Romans 12?
It's the same concept, it's the same idea.
And it starts with notice, it starts with a humble stance.
It it starts with this, this idea, I'm not gonna try
to push someone else down so that I'm raised up.
I'm not self-focused.
I'm not conceited where it's all about me.
That's what he's saying. It starts there.
And then it also is others focused.
'cause he says building up the interests of others, right?
That sounds like honor, doesn't it?
I'm gonna honor, I'm gonna build you up as I sit back.
Okay? So let's just apply this
really simple way here in our day and age.
What if instead of posturing with our wealth
or our, our reputation
or our abilities, like where we just kind
of put ourselves forward
and make sure everybody knows how wealthy we are,
how amenable we are, how, how reputable we are,
and we're just trying to make sure everybody knows
and we're positioning ourselves in a way that
that makes ourselves look really good.
What if instead of posturing like that, each of us
instead gave every effort
to being the most humble person on the face of the earth.
What if we put our efforts not
to making ourselves look better or to look more prominent?
And we gave our efforts to being more humble
and that was our goal, that was our effort.
What if we did that where our, our effort was
to fade into the background, to elevate others
above ourselves, to push other people
forward so that they win?
What if we were the guy
or girl on the team
who was most focused on the most assists in the game,
rather than the most points in the game, right?
You just become the the assist person
because you know when you pass the ball
and they make the shot, your team wins.
But you don't have to make the shot.
You just say, I'm gonna assist. I'm gonna be the assist guy.
I'm gonna be the assist girl. Now I'm just gonna give my
life away so that everybody else wins
because I know when they win, I win.
What kind of atmosphere would that create around here?
What kind of atmosphere would that create if all
of us are focused on honoring each other humbly
and stepping back and saying, I'm not gonna be the first,
I'm gonna be last and I'm gonna push everyone else forward
and elevate others above myself.
What kinda culture would that create?
Now listen, I wanna encourage you as a church right now,
I've been here seven years now this week
and I have seen growth
in us as a church.
I know I've grown yet
that growth for me has been a painful growth
Because the Lord has used relational
and even physical struggles to wean me off
of self dependence.
I, for so long in my life, I saw my gifts, my abilities,
as somehow mine.
Like therefore my benefit.
I created them somehow mentally, physically, spiritually.
Like they, they were, they were all about me
and I was using them for myself.
And that pride was crippling me.
It was keeping me from what God had for my life.
And so what God did over the last number of years
was systematically stripped away my health,
my church growth dreams stripped away.
My selfish desire for no conflict, innate in me from
before, right, from long ago was like,
I wanna avoid conflict.
And he's like, that's not how life works, man.
That's not how ministry is.
He stripped away all of those things. Why was he doing that?
To draw me to himself.
And so I've grown in this very area
And again, I've seen us grow as a church in this very area.
Like as a pastor and we as elders, we, we sit around
and watch and we serve with of course,
but just to, to observe so many humble men
and women, setting aside selfish ambition
and just saying, I'm gonna delight in serving one another
even if nobody knows who I am or what I'm doing
or anybody ever finds out about it.
I'm gonna serve in real quiet ways
and push everybody forward.
Like we sit back and we watch that happen
and it fills our souls to watch that happen every day.
'cause there are times that we know things
that you are serving and doing that nobody else knows.
And we are so encouraged by that. Praise God for that.
We watch it, we see it. It is so encouraging.
So praise God and and stay at it, right?
Yet we're not finished growing, right?
See, compared to a lot of people, a lot of churches we are,
we're doing pretty well, right?
We're, we're pretty vertical in this.
So be encouraged,
but also remember that compared to Christ,
we have some realigning left to do.
And so we can be content but never satisfied.
So praise God for what he's done.
But we are not finished yet.
So lemme just challenge you with this today, tomorrow,
every day in
God's power, wrestle to the ground,
whatever is left of your selfish prideful self.
Like put it to death 'cause it's still there.
I look at my heart every day
and I'm like, yeah, that was pretty selfish.
Yeah, that pride still creeps up.
It's still there in every one of us.
And so in God's power, wrestle it to the ground
and put it to death
because we want to be more humble.
That's how it starts. That's where we have to begin.
'cause what God will do with that is he'll humbly turn your
heart more towards honoring one another
as your heart is more humble.
So honor starts with humility.
The second point today flows naturally outta that one.
Because here's what happens.
Whenever we say things like I just said head,
there's a common pushback.
There's this feeling that comes up. I feel it.
I know it's there. Okay, so you're telling me this call
to be humble, alright?
I need to step back, step aside.
I need to push people forward all this,
but won't that make me a doormat?
Like that means people are just gonna run over me,
take advantage of me.
That that's what, that's right.
So, so you're telling me that's what I need to be now.
Now will you get hurt at
times, yes.
Will you get taken advantage of at times? Yes.
Jesus certainly did a number of times.
So you'll be in good company.
But, but here's what I want us to think about.
Not not the negative consequences of what could happen.
Think differently about this idea
because the way God's word talks about honoring others is
it's actually the best way to lead someone else.
Honor leads through value
like honor that we're talking about here is actually the way
to lead as you value others.
This gets to that definition talking about worth
and cost, right?
There's a respect given to someone
because you see their worth.
Let me just remind you of one of our values as a church.
It's the value of compelling love.
It's how we phrased it here.
We demonstrate the love of Jesus by respecting the dignity
of every person, sacrificing for our neighbors
and cultivating unity with our faith family.
In other words, Jesus has loved us in this way.
So we turn around and love others in this way. Simple.
But that starts, remember Philippians two, that starts
by seeing others as more significant than yourself
by counting them as more valuable than yourself,
that their value exceeds yours.
Now, I'm not saying you're not valuable,
I'm just saying you in your heart are counting them
as more valuable than you are.
More significant. Which only happens
when you see them as the image bearer of God
that they actually are right.
That's the foundation here. It's a theological truth.
All humans, no matter how far gone,
all humans are created in the image of God.
That's Genesis 1 27.
All the way back at the beginning,
what God said when creating humans, here's how it went.
So God created man in his own image, in the image of God.
He created him. Male and female, he created them.
Every man and woman who's ever lived is
created in the image of God.
That's simple. Now, sin has tarnished that image.
And so it's like looking in a foggy mirror like you,
you open the shower door after shower
and it's like the bathroom fills with steam
and you can't see anything.
You can see that there's still an image there,
but it's really fuzzy.
That's like we are as humans now.
The image is still there.
It's just tarnished and tainted and,
and that you can't see it as clearly.
It's the same way because of sin
that has happened in us, but it's still there.
Don't forget, it's still there in every person which demands
respect and dignity given to that person
because they're in the image of God.
It doesn't mean you agree with everything they do
because I don't even agree with myself all the time.
It means you respect them and you show them dignity
because it's an honor thing.
As we've seen here. And here's what happens.
When you treat people like that's true,
they tend to follow you.
They, they tend to listen more.
Like there's a leadership principle here and,
and so when you think about leadership,
there's a couple different options.
You have more than what I'm about to share.
But here's just a few of them. How do you lead people?
Well, you could lead people outta fear, get them to fear you
and they'll follow you for a while.
But the culture will be terrible
and eventually that team will wanna quit.
So it works one way.
Another option is you could be like the self-proclaimed
world's best boss
who was asked if he would rather be feared or loved.
He said, easy. Both.
I would want people to be afraid of how much they love me.
Maybe not best practice there,
but in reality,
the best way to lead people is to value them.
To honor them like we see in Romans 1210
to respect people, to treat them as the image
of bear of God that they are.
Now I know you're sitting there
thinking, but I'm not a leader.
Well, that might be true in the sense
that you don't have a platform.
You don't have a blue check by your name online.
You don't have a title that makes you a leader.
Okay, I get that. Sure.
But you do have massive influence on others.
Every one of us. 'cause the Bible talks about the church
in such a way that we are
to be leading one another toward Jesus.
His good, pleasing and perfect will.
Like that's what we're all called
to help each other get towards and find direction towards.
That's what we are leading each other,
influencing each other towards that.
And so let's just play it out.
Imagine a world where there's negative things
of what I've just talked about here, where the culture
is one of each of us are discouraging one another.
Each of us are posturing of how we can be this way
or that we're climbing over each other to be prominent,
to be in this position over that.
And we wanna push you down so we win.
Like imagine that's the culture. What's gonna happen?
People will be pushed away from Jesus.
Our kids might grow up
and as soon as they're gone,
they completely a abandon this thing
because they're like, I don't want anything to
part any part of that.
That's a mess. And no one
potentially pursues the path God has for them.
Nobody sees value in them
and so they don't see that they're valuable to God.
Does it have to be that way?
If the culture's bad, people can still come outta
that and follow Jesus?
Absolutely. But the likelihood is a lot lower.
Imagine the other side of that.
Imagine let's flip the script ripped to where every one
of us is.
Instead now valuing one another,
we're championing each other's strengths.
We are celebrating people in what they're doing and good at.
What happens then? Man, that's an attractive place to be.
People are drawn to the Lord
because they're seeing something that is not natural.
They're seeing something that's supernatural,
that only God can do through a group of people.
And they're like, I wanna be a part of that.
Not only 'cause it's encouraging, but
because I see something different in you guys.
People are drawn to the Lord and we see people called out
and up to God's amazing plan for their life
that God's got a purpose for every single person he created.
And we can look at each other
and say, here's what I see in you.
Here's what I appreciate about you.
Here's what I see God doing in your life.
Here's where you could go. And we're calling that out.
And more people are saying, man, I'm gonna do that.
I think I can do that. Encouraging towards that, just like
that guy sat across the table from me at lunch
and said, you're gonna be a pastor someday.
I didn't see it, But he did.
So again, you doing this, when you
and I take ownership
and lead like this,
that's influencing others towards God's purpose.
For us, that's leadership.
That's something we can be about as a church.
I hope it painted a picture that's an appealing future.
But here's what's interesting about this sermon series, just
through Romans 12, taking piece by piece.
Here's what interesting about, interesting about it.
It seems like every week we come to the same point,
about two thirds of the way through the sermon we,
we paint this beautiful picture
of whatever it is we've been talking about that day.
And we look at Jesus in his perfect standard
and we see how how great it looks for us
to be living that out.
Like if we would realign ourselves to what Jesus did
and how he lived it out, man, it would be so life giving.
This would be a perfect place to be. We, we see that.
But the question always comes up at this point, okay, how?
How in the world do we ever get to that point?
Because innate in us is competition is putting you down.
So I win, right? That's, that's innate flesh stuff.
So how do we ever get to delighting
in showing honor to one another?
How do we get to loving each other?
Like Christ loved the church like,
like Trevor talked about last year carrying last week
carrying for each other, right?
And and real tangible boys, how do we get there?
Like those things come up every single time
we hit this point.
So how do we get to this honor?
Well, here's the final point.
It's gonna answer that question. Hopefully honor
flows from honor.
How do we ever get to this point?
It's because honor flows from honor.
Like when you pick up a dry sponge
and squeeze it, that's pretty useless, right?
We can't give what we don't have.
So here's what I mean by that. Think back to
that part of Philippians two.
I read earlier how the church maintains unity.
I'm gonna read it again. This is Philippians two.
Verses three and four says, do nothing from selfish ambition
or conceit, but in humility,
count others more significant than yourselves.
Let each of you look not only to his own interests,
but also to the interests of others.
Again, that's the desired future.
That's the picture painted of the way we should be.
Well look at what happens next.
In verse five, Have this mind
among yourselves, which is yours in
Christ Jesus.
Did you see that? What he's saying there?
He's like, think and act like I just described in verses
three and four, humble self serving, others, looking
to count others more significant.
Do all of that. Verse five says,
because you already have the mind to be able to do it.
Now, verse five is so interesting
because notice, it's like there's a command and a promise.
He says, have this mind among yourselves.
That's a command that basically he's saying
think like Jesus.
Well then you're thinking, well how? How can I do that?
I then what does he finish with?
Because you already have the mind of Christ.
Have this mind in yourselves because you already have it.
You can think like this.
You can't act like what I just described,
because you have the mind of Christ.
Now, what he's saying is that if you are a believer,
if you've turned from your sin
and turned from yourself in Jesus for your salvation,
you can now think like he thinks.
You have the mind of Christ.
Corinthians says, you, you can think
and act like this.
You can grow in your ability
to understand what he wants you to do.
It's what Romans 12, two said.
Remember, you are not to be conformed to this world,
but you're to be transformed by the renewal of your mind.
That by testing you may discern what's the will of God,
good, acceptable, and perfect.
So again, you have the mind of Christ.
Now you can grow in your renewal of
that mind over time.
That is how we begin to compete at out honoring one another.
Because just stop and think for a second.
How did Christ honor you? How did he honor people?
He the mind of Christ is what we're talking about.
So how did he do it?
Well, he respected you enough
and saw you as valuable enough
to pay the highest price in order to redeem you.
How did he do that? Well, Philippians two continues,
verses six through eight,
after five says, have this mind among yourselves,
which is yours in Christ Jesus.
Who though he was in the form of God, did not count equality
with God a thing to be grasped or held onto.
But he emptied himself, taking the form of a servant,
being born in the likeness of men
and being found in human form.
He humbled himself by becoming obedient to the point
of death, even death on a cross.
Again, that was the value God placed on you.
That was the price tag for your redemption.
That was the honor he gave you by doing what he did.
And there was no other way,
no other sacrifice was sufficient to do what he did.
He had to do it that way. That is honor.
But hear me church, that then what Jesus did is our example
and our motivation and our power
to go about honoring one another as Christ has honored us.
He humbled himself. He offered himself, he gave himself away
because we're valuable to him.
It's the same way we now can humble ourselves
and serve one another and give ourselves away
because we honor another.
We lay aside. Just think about this, Jesus, what he did.
Lay aside our privileges, our positions to serve others,
counting them as more significant than ourselves,
even dying to self in order to honor them.
It's what Jesus did. It's
what what we can then do for others.
You see how that will create such an appealing, exciting,
sweet life-giving culture within a church.
If all of us are doing that for one another, that is
pretty incredible place
that people would wanna be a part of.
I didn't finish that section of Philippians two though,
because to this point it might seem like we
are the focus here.
It might seem like Jesus did all that he did up
to Philippians two, eight,
and then he just fades into the background
that in some way we don't need him anymore.
Like what we can see in this.
If we leave it here, it can start to puff us up a little bit
that we don't really need Jesus.
We just needed him to start this self-help cult.
And then we can continue it on from here.
That as long as we are enough, uh, honoring and encouraging
and building each other up, man,
we don't need Jesus anymore.
Because if that's what it, what it is, if
that's all it is, we don't need him.
We can just make sure that we're being enough,
honoring being enough, affirming
and encouraging to each other.
Yeah. Then we don't, okay, well
let's finish Philippians two.
'cause watch what happens after Jesus did
in his incarnation, his perfect life,
his sacrificial death on the cross.
Watch what Jesus did and what happens.
Philippians two verses nine through 11,
therefore now again that's a,
a really important word, links us back.
It says, because of all that has just been said, all
that Jesus did all that he's about all
that he is, all of that.
Therefore, God has highly exalted
him and bestowed on him the name that is above every name,
so that at the name of Jesus,
every niche should bow in heaven and on earth
and under the earth and every tongue confess
that Jesus Christ is Lord to the glory of God the Father.
And so let me be clear.
While it is important that all people are honored
because they bear the image of God,
there is only one name worthy of being worshiped.
And that's the name of Jesus Christ.
Like it's fine and important.
It's commanded for us to honor each other,
but we need to honor and praise and exalt
and worship the one who this is all really about.
That's Jesus, the God
who humbled himself to live the perfect life.
We couldn't live the God who died,
the death we deserve the God who defeated the enemy of sin
and death that we could never defeat on our own.
That's why he is worthy of our honor.
That's why he is worthy of our praise
and He's worthy of our lives.
And that's then how he's the power
and motivation for us to turn around and honor one another.
Like he's honored us. We desperately need him.
We don't leave him behind so we can go honor each other
and build each other up.
We desperately need him to flow through us to honor others
as he has honored us.
And so it's a great place
to be when people are honoring each other.
Yes, but there's only one name worthy
of our whole devotion, our whole lives.
It's him. And so let's bow our heads together, if you would,
and let's just reflect on that in His word
and what he's done and
what we've seen him speak and do today.
Now, I'll just invite you to, to ask him a question.
Simple.
Say, God, I I want to be more stunned
by what you have done for me.
Can you help me? Like if this
Philippians two picture of Jesus is true,
we should be just dumbfounded by that.
Amazed, stunned, overwhelmed by God
who would do that
for you, A sinner for me, a sinner.
He would do that.
Ask him to help just reawaken your heart
towards those things today.
And just in light of that, ask him to give you
a renewed sense of how to honor others,
to reorient your heart,
to refocus your heart away from yourself, to get out
of yourself and to think and consider others
that your identity is secure in him.
You don't have to posture, you don't have to position.
You can just serve and fade into the background.
Be unknown because you have a secure
identity in him.
Ask him to reorient your heart towards people like that.
Lord, we need you. This is not natural to us.
And so, Lord, we know it must be supernatural.
You must do it. Pray you would in our hearts that that each
of us would look around and look for ways to honor
and ways to encourage
and ways to celebrate each other,
to outdo one another in that.
Lord, I pray that would be culture here.
I thank you that it already is in so many ways,
but God may, may it just overflow out of here to
where people around us can't help but see it.
But that helps that that comes from,
from seeing you first God as
who you are and what you've done.
So stun us with that reality.
Awaken our affections for you more.
Even as we sing, as we respond, as we live today,
as we play volleyball, as we go to work, as we go to camp.
Whatever it is, Lord, just stir our affections
for you in those things.
In Jesus' name, amen.
And so we are gonna give an opportunity to sing in response
to him in this moment here in a few seconds.
But, but we also, we see the time
of giving each week as that as well.
It's not just collecting money, it's a sense
of this is also worship.
Worship's not just singing. This is also worship.
And so whether it's in this moment, in the plates or online
or in the boxes or during the week or
whenever it is, it's, it's saying to God,
which is what worship is.
Same God, all, all, all of me is yours. I, I know nothing.
I own nothing. This is all yours.
And you're, you're giving me a chance to steward it.
So I wanna steward it for your glory for others. Good.
This is a way on by the way.
This is a way to serve and to lift up,
build others up just by giving.
Just say this is for you, God. This is all yours.
Anyway, I'm just gonna give it to you for your purposes.
So I'm invite the ushers to come forward
as we receive that now.
But all the rest of us, if you are able,
let's stand together and in our hearts respond
to this God who's done all that He's done for us in honor.